[Musica]
nel caffè che avete bevuto prima o che
verrete domattina magari ripensando a
questo stesso talk accadranno dei
fenomeni misteriosi complessi quanto
quelli che creiamo accadono nello spazio
più remoto tra le galassie il cervello
che userete per pensare a tutto questo
bene sappiate che in base alla fisica
moderna
e uno degli oggetti più complessi
dell'universo complesso almeno tanto
quanto la distribuzione di tutte le
galassie che potremo mai osservare
nell'universo
queste cose non sono delle sparate di
fantascienza o peggio di pseudo scienza
sono dei punti lungo il percorso che
fisica astrofisica stanno compiendo
nella direzione di includere concetti
idee dalla teoria della complessità che
è un campo di ricerca molto vasto molto
interdisciplinare e che è stato premiato
come forse ricorderete circa un mese fa
con il premio nobel alla fisica
l'italiano giorgio parisi tra le tante
cose che spero vi via fascino che vi
racconterò oggi vorrei che me ne
restasse a meno 1 impressa noi crediamo
in fisica che quando due eventi sono
veramente complessi anche se avvengono
su scale di tempo e di spazio
incredibilmente diverse e sto per
mostrarvi forse i due estremi possibili
nel nostro diverso
questi fenomeni possono essere simili
tra di loro perché indipendentemente
dalle interazioni dalle forze
fondamentali che li regolano possono
auto creare un livello di organizzazione
che risponde a dinamiche a logiche
superiori che li fanno appunto
assomigliare prima di parlare di tutto
questo
vi racconto un po di me quando ero più
giovane diciamo proprio più piccolo
avrei voluto essere questo un archeologo
questa cosa che vedete è un reperto
archeologico
anch'esso è una ricerca sugli antichi
fenici credo di seconda o terza
elementare vela mostro perché ritornerà
più avanti
avrei voluto studiare il passato della
civiltà umana per capirne meglio il
presente beh gli astronomi non fanno una
cosa molto diversa cercano di sfondare
il passato remoto universo andando
veramente miliardi e miliardi di anni in
là nel tempo sia con la teoria sia con
le osservazioni dove riescono con
l'obiettivo di spiegare quello che
invece i telescopi ci mostrano
nell'universo attorno a noi vi mostro un
caso un caso pratico almeno per noi
astrofisici questo è un caso pratico
questo è un ammasso di galassie è una
grande megalopoli cosmica tutti i
puntini che vedete qui i poteri luminosi
non sono stelle sono single e galassie
sono single e cita stellari molto simili
alla nostra via lattea o magari diversi
della via lattea ma ciascuno di questi
punti luminosi contiene circa 100
miliardi di stelle in questo senso
questo è una grande provincia cosmica
fatta di tante città stellari che negli
ultimi miliardi di anni sono tenute
assieme dalla forza di gravità e
orbitano in modo caotico intorno al
centro di massa di questo sistema che è
steso milioni di anni luce una struttura
che vedete in basso invece in rosso è
chiamata relitto radio la possiamo
osservare invece se accediamo alla parte
radio dello spettro elettromagnetico
questa struttura è gigante e lunga circa
6 milioni di anni luce da parte a parte
potrebbero starci comodamente almeno 50
galassie come la nostra messe una di
fila all'altra
è un ambiente di densità bassissima qui
la densità è un miliardo di miliardi di
miliardi di volte più bassa dell'aria
che respiriamo
ciò nonostante qui crediamo sia venuto
un grandissimo uno dei più grandi
cataclismi della storia dell'universo
questa che è una perturbazione vera e
propria si sta spostando noi crediamo
verso il basso dell'immagine alla
velocità di circa 6.000 chilometri al
secondo
nonostante la densità appunto qui sia
bassissima l'energia complessivamente
associata questa perturbazione che è
veramente un'onda di tsunami cosmica ci
fa dire che qui deve essere avvenuto
circa cinque miliardi di anni fa uno
degli eventi più cataclismatici più
energetici dell'intera vita
dell'universo conosciamo tanti sistemi
come questo questo è uno dei più
spettacolari come facciamo a capire che
cosa è avvenuto qui gli astrofisici
fanno qualcosa di simile a quello che
fanno i metereologi cerchiamo di fare
delle previsioni del tempo però noi
prevediamo il passato abbiamo delle
osservazioni che si raccontano più il
presente astrofisico cerchiamo di
chiederci cosa è successo nel passato e
quali leggi fisiche hanno prodotto
quello che osserviamo adesso come fanno
i metereologi inseriamo in un
calcolatore le forze fondamentali che
crediamo di conoscere sono quattro in
natura le componenti di materia
principale evolviamo quello che queste
equazioni fanno ci occorrono tanti
computer usiamo il calcolo parallelo
migliaia e migliaia di computer che
lavorano in simultanea e facciamo una
storia presunta del passato
dell'universo poi la confrontiamo con le
osservazioni
se il modello si accorda bene stiamo
imparando qualcosa però questo difficile
perché siamo di fronte ad uno dei
fenomeni più complessi ma anche comuni
dell'universo la turbolenza dei fluidi
voi potete fare l'esperimento per
esempio domattina se proverete a
mescolare tante volte le stesse poche
gocce di caffè per esempio in una tazza
di latte prevedere meglio il contrasto
vedrete che se li fate lo stesso
esperimento tante volte non riuscirete
mai a prevedere esattamente che
strutture si formeranno voi potrete dire
che dopo qualche secondo latte caffè si
saranno miscelati ma le strutture che si
andranno a formare esattamente da un
caso all'altro saranno sempre diverse
questo perché la turbolenza è un regime
della fisica nella quale i fluidi sono
soggetti a una cosiddetta non linearità
delle minuscole differenze nelle
condizioni iniziali per esempio l'angolo
con cui mettete la tazzina il cucchiaino
nella tazza di caffè di latte cambia
l'evoluzione da campo in modo
completamente divergente completamente
diverso da una storia volta siamo in un
regime caotico quindi anche se ci
arrabbiamo con i metereologi perché
sbagliano la previsione del tempo da qui
a due giorni volevamo andare al mare
invece piove
sappiate che nemmeno con tutta la
potenza di calcolo disponibile al mondo
voi sapreste prevedere che cosa
succederà nella vostra da tina di caffè
domani esattamente
applicando questo a questo problema
all'astrofisica dobbiamo produrre
simulazioni al computer estremamente
grandi estremamente lunghe e farne tante
e vedere quella che meglio si accorda
con i dati quella che vi mostro è quella
che il mio gruppo ha prodotto che meglio
si accorda con la formazione di quel
relitto radio che dimostrava all'inizio
state per vedere l'evoluzione in pochi
secondi di quello che crediamo sia
successo in cinque miliardi di anni e
quello che state per vedere sono come
queste masse di gas rarefatti simo in
giallo arancione si mescolano tra di
loro trascinato dalla forza di gravità
delle galassie che stanno evolvendo in
questo sistema le tracce azzurro è solo
dove noi possiamo prevedere che si
formino questi lampi radio verso nel
fieno di questi lampi radio simulati si
sovrappone molto bene al vero relitto
radio osservato questa è una vera
immagine
possiamo quindi dire che abbiamo un
modello simulato che tiene conto delle
interazioni fondamentali della natura
che qui ci interessano che sono
soprattutto la gravità e la
fluidodinamica il modo in cui fluidi si
mescolano tra di loro e tutto questo ci
dà un modello fedele di un fenomeno per
esempio straw fisico che vogliamo
studiare la possibilità di avere
simulazioni accurate di un qualche
fenomeno fisico e anche fondamentale per
rispondere un'altra domanda
apparentemente più evanescente ma però è
molto affascinante che cos'è la
complessità come faccio a dire che
qualcosa e complesso come faccio a
quantificarlo come faccio a paragonare
tra di loro fenomeni che penso essere
complessi ma che sono di tipo
completamente diverso qui sfruttiamo
un'idea che è partita in realtà 50 60
anni fa per esempio da un fisico
sovietico
geniale e andrea è colmo goro che non
casualmente ha fatto anche molti studi
sulla turbolenza noi possiamo dire che
la lunghezza del programma diciamo
dell'algoritmo che usiamo per fare una
simulazione e la quantità di dati che
occorra il programma per iniziare a
funzionare e produrre la simulazione
sono una misura molto accurata o la
migliore misura possibile della
complessità del fenomeno stesso che non
è molto diverso dal dire che un piatto
di alta cucina è più complesso
tipicamente si richiede una ricetta
molto lunga e magari molti ingredienti e
noi sappiamo come misurare la quantità
di informazione informatica tramite il
numero di bit tramite le unità di codice
binario zero o uno che ci occorrono per
codificare una certa sequenza di dati
oppure possiamo usare il multiplo debiti
che sono i byte 8 bit fanno un bite
questo è importante perché
ritornando un attimo l'archeologia come
vedete non ho mai abbandonato del tutto
è una specie di stele di rosetta la
stele di rosetta è questo documento
questo
questa lastra di granito che circa 220
anni fa è stata usata per la prima volta
per decifrare il linguaggio geroglifico
perché in questa lastra è riportato lo
stesso editto del faraone in geroglifico
che era ignoto all'epoca in un'altra
variante dell'egizio antico anche
segnata e le greco antico che invece era
conosciuto avendo in uno stesso
documento le trascrizioni della stessa
informazione in diversi linguaggi
abbiamo potuto conoscere per la prima
volta il significato del linguaggio
geroglifico usando lo stesso approccio
da qualche anno sto
sia simulando l'universo come si fa in
tanti centri di ricerca in questo caso
simulando l'intera rete o una grande
porzione della rete cosmica delle
galassie e usando gli stessi reati
astrofisici per estrarre dal flusso di
dati prodotto dalla simulazione anche la
quantità di bit che descrivono
l'evoluzione di tante parti diverse per
esempio dell'universo che vedete la
formazione di due ammassi di galassie in
centro queste strutture più più rosse
possiamo usare questo dato per esempio
per farne un normale studio astrofisico
come questo che vedete è un
ingrandimento che dimostra l'energia
associata a queste perturbazioni del gas
che servono la formazione di un ammasso
di galassie
questa invece la mappa della complessità
che possiamo estrarre dal flusso di dati
della simulazione con metodi un po
avanzati e è una mappa veramente
colorata in unità di bit dove i colori
sono più accesi ii avvenuta l'evoluzione
più complessa dove abbiamo pochi colori
l'evoluzione stata molto semplice per
esempio nei vuoti cosmici questo ci
permette veramente di quantificare la
complessità con un numero che posso
confrontare una cosa che posso fare è
estrapolare queste simulazioni che non
arrivano mai a coprire la totalità
dell'universo osservabile che stimiamo
abbia un raggio di 46 miliardi di anni e
di anni luce noi non possiamo mai
coprire tutto l'universo osservabile con
un'unica simulazione possiamo però
estrapolare dati dei campioni molto
grandi simulati e una stima verosimile
che per descrivere l'evoluzione
dell'intera rete cosmica ci occorrono 32
milioni di miliardi di bit ovvero circa
4 petabyte e mezzo
quante questo numero è tanto e poco
sembra gigantesco in effetti lo è però è
dell'ordine dei dati che produce ogni
giorno una grande rete sociale complessa
come quella di facebook però se
volessimo a fermarci a qualcosa di
ancora più affascinante è che portiamo
qui tutti quanti in questo momento
la rete neuronale la rete dei neuroni
del nostro cervello stato stimato che
possa codificare possa contenere una
quantità di memoria molto simile dello
stesso ordine di grandezza allora
qualche anno fa mi sono rivolto a un
nero chirurgo di fama internazionale che
attualmente lavora presso l'ospedale e
l'università di verona per proporgli un
confronto quantitativo tra campioni
simulati del web della rete cosmica di
galassie e campioni reali del cervello
umano
abbiamo in effetti prodotto questo
lavoro che uscito alla fine dell'anno
scorso in una rivista scientifica
questo lavoro è stato ripreso quasi
istantaneamente dai media di mezzo mondo
tradotto in tutte le lingue
aggiunti insomma a riprova della grande
fascino che questo tema esercita su di
noi e non è stata in realtà la nostra
prima ricerca assieme la prima però già
mostrata eravamo in effetti compagni di
banco le elementari
diciamo che questa seconda ricerca è
stata letta e apprezzata da un po più di
persone
che cosa abbiamo trovato allora abbiamo
analizzato in modo quantitativo
quantitative oggettivo con gli stessi
metodi presi soprattutto
dall'astrofisica e dalla scienza delle
reti complesse dei campioni diversi sia
della rete cosmica simulata sia di
campioni di vetrini ottenuti al
microscopio della corteccia cerebrale e
del cervelletto due parti fondamentali
del cervello umano
li abbiamo analizzati in modo simile
abbiamo trovato una quantità in effetti
stupefacente di simili somiglianze
allora il numero di nodi ovvero galassie
in un caso o neuroni nell'alta sono
molto simili 100 miliardi stimiamo siano
le galassie 80 miliardi sono i neuroni
stimiamo abbiamo realizzato la topologia
delle due reti ovvero abbiamo
schematizzato queste reti come una
sequenza di nodi e filamenti che
connettono la rete spazialmente abbiamo
trovato dei parametri molto simile il
numero di nodi e degli di quote di
connessioni di filamenti per notano i
due casi è molto simile la tendenza che
i nodi anno a raggrupparsi in macro nodi
formando degli hub come quelli degli
aeroporti è molto simile abbiamo
utilizzato una tecnica astrofisica
chiamata spettro di potenza che si usa
molto anche per per la cosmologia per
studiare come la massa si distribuisca o
tre i vuoti ei pieni nei due sistemi in
modo molto simile el'impronta che questa
questo spettro di potenza a è molto
diversa se applichiamo la stessa tecnica
ad altri sistemi naturali apparentemente
simili abbiamo ricavato di nuovo la
complessità totale dei due sistemi che
sembra essere dello stesso ordine di
grandezza
questo molto affascinante perché abbiamo
a che fare con due sistemi che sono
separati tra di loro da 27 ordini di
grandezza in scala spazi scale spaziali
da una parte abbiamo miliardi di anni
luce dall altra parte abbiamo dieci
centimetri grosso modo
che cosa ci dice tutto questo vi dico
che cosa non ci dice non ci dice che il
cervello umano contiene un universo non
ci dice che l'universo è un cervello
pensante
nulla di tutto ciò
tutto questo ci ripete qualcosa che vi
accennavo all'inizio siamo in presenza
dei due spettacolari fenomeni emergenti
ovvero abbiamo due sistemi la cui
evoluzione è è prescritta dalle
interazioni semplici in un caso e la
forza di gravità dall'altra parte
abbiamo scambi di forte elettrochimiche
in entrambi i casi abbiamo tantissime
componenti che interagiscono tra di loro
da questo marasma di interazioni
emergono delle strutture queste che
possiamo schematizzare come reti
complesse che tendono ad assomigliarsi i
fenomeni emergenti ne conosciamo
tantissimi in natura noi scopriamo
sempre di più noi stessi siamo un
fenomeno emergente è una cosa
affascinante che la possiamo applicare
per esempio per visualizzare la
creazione di branchi di animali o di
stormi di uccelli la crescita dei
batteri il propagarsi dell'epidemia o
loro contrasto tramite vaccini tema che
non ti devi dica è estremamente
d'attualità la creazione di reti sociali
con poli dominanti eccetera tutte queste
non sono esempi della stessa rete
complessa in alcun modo ma sono tutti i
fenomeni emergenti fenomeni nei quali la
moltitudine delle interazioni semplici
di componenti microscopiche di un
sistema crea qualcosa che vediamo solo
quando facciamo un passo indietro ci
allontaniamo e cominciamo a vedere uno
l'azione su scala più grande
per concludere cosa possiamo dire da un
lato i fenomeni emergenti credo che
siano una frontiera che la fisica sta
già affrontando affronterà per esempio
in cosmologia
dobbiamo capire come ha fatto l'universo
partendo dalla situazione più omogenea
isotropa che potete immaginare 13
miliardi di anni fa a creare questa
incredibile gerarchia di struttura della
scala sul nucleare
atomica e molecolare gli organismi
pianeti le stelle le galassie la rete
dell'universo e così via e dall'altra
parte lo dico l'astrofisico una cosa che
a me affascina assolutamente che trovo
inspiegabile come l'interazione continua
di questa moltitudine di 80 miliardi di
cellule sostanzialmente ignare l'una
dell'altra e riesca continuamente a
creare questa struttura persistente
molto astratta va molto reale perché la
stiamo vivendo in questo istante che è
la nostra coscienza che siamo noi stessi
è che la curiosità che ci spinge a fare
domande così formidabili sull'universo
stesso
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]